and so when you start to think about the
lightning network i know that you've
spent some time on this i've seen you
tweet about it a couple of times over
the last couple of weeks um what's your
assessment as to where we are today and
uh kind of why are you so excited about
that uh you know i'm very very bullish i
feel like i'm so biased at this point
that i can't even
be honest about my analysis anymore so
maybe you can uh kind of explain to
folks why you're so bullish on it
well just
it's probably easier just to use a
specific example and think about what
might happen in the market what we do
what's what you might do if you're a
business
um visa charges between two and a half
and three and a half percent to
businesses
lightning is
almost zero
it so that means as a business you could
increase your net profits or you could
increase your profits by by that amount
and when businesses are operating on the
low margins that's a big amount to be
able to increase their their their
profits by so businesses are going to
enable this and they're going to
encourage users to use more and they'll
give discounts likely to users who use
more of lightning network and once that
starts what you see mcdonald's in el
salvador you see starbucks in el
salvador using lightning
so
in an instant it's available in el
salvador what do you think is going to
happen
next when mcdonald's looks across the
world at their other stores and where
else can we implement this because we
make more money
and if we make more money and all
businesses are starting to make more
money as a result
then competition will come to lower
prices again and
again technology that empowers people
and lowers the price of things
is very very hard to stop
and i the question is why would you want
to stop it
because you're saying
we can't stop we won't allow this
because it helps people
and so
so as a result of that you're going to
see this this explode in um i think
around the world because there's an
incentive structure that helps people
when you start to think about the
adoption of this asset we've recently
seen el salvador obviously make it legal
tender um to me
we've seen something similar maybe in
the past where if you look at like m
pesa and mobile banking there's a number
of countries in africa that seemed to
have leapfrogged the united states right
you talked a little bit earlier about
the developed nation uh really having um
almost a privilege right that we have
something that works good enough and so
we don't think about the cutting-edge
technology and the need to be innovative
and adopt that is that what's happening
here is these developed nations
basically are saying hey we're so far
behind and the only way that we can make
progress is to kind of make this giant
leap forward this is the best technology
today and so let's go ahead and kind of
make a bet on it or is there something
else at play with with the developed
nation uh developing nations whether
it's el salvador um somewhere like in
nigeria uh that seem to really be
embracing this technology
i think a little bit of both but uh but
um but
again going back to a business example
and i'll use myself one of my my first
company um
yahoo and a bunch of different media
companies yahoo specifically it was the
kind of tech enabled but it charges a
minimum of 5000 a month for for
advertising google was free
so where did we build our resources we
built it to google
and besides yahoo
the the rest of the the infrastructure
look like large
media empires that we couldn't afford to
advertise on so what ended up happening
is what
the
the smaller companies the long tail of
all of the small companies drive
adoption first same thing happened in
the internet in general it's a small
companies that drive adoption not the
big big ones because the big ones have
access and they have privileged access
already they don't see it
same thing happened on amazon um it
wasn't all of the all of the stores all
the
merchants that were in walmart that went
on amazon it was all the merchants that
didn't have access to walmart
so what you can see in that is when you
have a technology that empowers people
what happens is the people that are most
underprivileged or who are who don't
have access to the existing system
use it first and they create a
network effect that more and more users
and they create more and more value in
that network as they use it
which brings on bigger and bigger
players all the time if you looked at
what was happening on on on bitcoin and
lightning that's exactly what's
happening and you could just abstract
instead of
just just happening at the company or
personal level it's now happening at a
country level as well
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]